okay donald trump had a completely
propagandistic 1984 style town hall
yesterday
he took questions from americans via
video while sitting
at the lincoln memorial yesterday we
believe that it was donald trump who had
selected the lincoln memorial
as the location but then during this
event donald trump said oh no
you guys told you guys being fox news
you guys told us you wanted it at the
lincoln memorial the two fox hosts brett
bayer and martha mccallum
visibly confused about wait a second i
thought we were here because you wanted
us here
doesn't even matter that's only the tip
of the iceberg my friends because
it was an absolute and complete
nightmare
now because we're doing fewer and fewer
of the briefings
i do think it's important to bring you a
sense of what the president is
communicating
and in relation to our segment earlier
today on whether the united states
is a failed state of sorts last night's
town hall was
more than illuminating in that sense now
first of all donald trump came
in absolutely shot out of a cannon like
he was on some kind of upper
and we've talked about this before trump
visibly very sweaty
sniffing repeating himself more than
usual
clenching his jaw unable to sit still
and you know we know about these two
versions of trump you've got
upper trump and then you've got downer
trump as i like to call them
something very strange seems to continue
with donald trump
along those lines it's tough to analyze
and we may never know
the full scope of that let's put the
sort of
uh appearance aside and focus on the
content
what we can more easily analyze was the
absolutely debased and abominable things
that donald trump
said along with the complete and total
lack of
truth in almost every single answer that
donald trump gave
it would be hard to do a more dishonest
town hall
he also barely answered any of the
questions in any
anything what we would call direct sense
but as we go through this
i want to frame it for you up front his
supporters loved it
his supporters loved it before we go
into the clips understand
that however you see donald trump as a
hopefully
rational sensible thinking person who
watches or listens to the david pakman
show
what you see in these upcoming clips his
followers
loved and saw as strong trump unwilling
to be bullied and pushed around
competent trump dealing with everything
perfectly
that's a really scary reality that we
have to come to terms with
let's get into it donald trump often
mentions the 1918
flu he often calls it the 1917 flu
this uh was a pandemic from about 100
years ago
it was late 1918 through early summer
of 1919 it affected infected rather it's
believed about 500 million
the death rate could have been the death
toll could have been anywhere from 17
million you hear 50 million you
sometimes hear 100 million based on the
numbers you look at
trump wildly claims without evidence
that the 1917 flu
ended world war one prematurely check
this out
right you remember the spanish flu so
much has been written about it now of
course it's the hottest
everybody that writes a book about the
spanish for 1917.
it killed between 100 and i guess 50 to
100
million people it probably ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were all getting sick
now this is not true it's simply not
true the war
sort of formally ended with the treaty
of versailles in june of 1919 but
fighting had mostly died down seven
months prior to that there's no question
that there were service
members around the world infected with
the flu
but this is a crazy thing for donald
trump to say
no pushback whatsoever from martha
mccallum and brett bayer not to defend
them but almost everything trump said on
this issue was false so
there was a sort of gish gallup effect
going on look that term up
if you're not familiar with it trump was
asked a question about how
he was supposedly getting intelligence
on the virus really early and he ignored
it
and donald trump claimed that he wasn't
told that the virus might be a thing
until january 23rd i'm going to play the
clip for you now remember
we had our first case on january 20th
that we know of we now know it was
obviously far earlier because of when
the first death happened but
there are two options here when trump
says he was first told this could be a
thing on january
23rd neither is good i'll tell them to
you after we watch the clip
because i did the right thing i saved
hundreds of thousands of lives okay
she's asking me the question about
intelligence i have the head of the
intelligence agencies here today
and here's the exact thing and we have
it it's going to be
released tomorrow the next day but i
released it today
on january 23rd i was told
that there could be a virus coming in
but it was
of no real import in other words it
wasn't oh we got to do something we got
to do something
so understand trump says he was told
january 23 the virus might come in
we had our first case three days earlier
okay we had our first case on january
20th
south korea had its first case right
around the same time
as as we did within hours of our first
case
they by january 23rd were already
developing a test
and setting up ways to contact trace and
isolate people
and trump is now claiming he was first
told this could be coming in
three days after the first case now
there's two options here
one is trump is just lying and i believe
trump is lying now
his me his brain may have turned to
mayonnaise
and he may not recall that he was being
briefed about this in early january
there are reports about briefings in
december there are now some reports
which we have not yet
fully corroborated that suggest in late
november this was already being
discussed
so trump could just be lying and saying
i didn't even really hear about this as
a serious thing until
three days after the first case that is
probably a lie
if it's true it's outrageous
that trump was not seriously warned
until three days after the first case
it goes against every bit of reporting
we have
i believe trump is lying or has
completely lost his memory
neither is good continuing with this
disgusting town hall
donald trump claims that he has been
treated
that he he has been treated worse than
abraham lincoln
and hilariously the person asking the
question actually said
why do you sometimes ramble without
asking questions that are asked of you
by the press here is dot part of donald
trump's answer
the question i have is about your manner
of presentation why do you use
descriptive words that could be
classified as bullying and why do not
directly answer the questions asked by
the press
but instead speak of past successes and
generally ramble
the usa needs you please let go of those
behaviors that are turning people away
from you
please hold on to your wonderful
attributes that make you our great
leader and let go of other
characteristics that do not serve you
good i think i like that question i'm
not sure but i think i like that
question i appreciate it i appreciate
the prayers too very much look uh
i am greeted with a hostile press the
likes of which no president has ever
seen
the closest would be that gentleman
right up there they always said lincoln
nobody got treated worse than lincoln i
believe
i am treated worse now of course abraham
lincoln
was assassinated okay trump is talking
about being treated worse
by the press than lincoln but again
trump's delusions delusions of grandeur
treated worse than anyone including
lincoln
because sometimes the press asks real
questions
and he never answers them and they have
to ask
again now on the death toll this is
really important and it's it's actually
tragic
donald trump is very casually moving the
goal posts
for close to a month donald trump has
been saying we're going to have 60 000
deaths thanks to me
could have had 1.5 million we could have
had 2.2 million but thanks to me
our death toll is going to be only 60
000. that ship has sailed we now are
already at almost 70
000 deaths in the united states so trump
has very
smoothly talked about listen we could
lose 80 or 90
000 and that would be terrible moving
the goal posts
take a look that's one of the reasons
we're successful that's one of the if
you call
losing 80 or 90 000 people successful
but it's one of the
reasons that we're not at that high end
of the plane as opposed to the low end
of that number has changed mr president
you said
it's going upstairs i used to say 65
000 and now i'm saying 80 or 90 and it
goes up and it goes up rapidly
but it's still going to be no matter how
you look at it at the very lower
end of the plane if we did the shutdown
now this was always the plan say some
insanely high number that would only
happen if he literally did nothing
and then say he gets credit for it being
less understand a couple of different
things
this 1.5 million 2.2 million trump for
the first time now floating 2.5 million
that may have been if he literally did
nothing
no president could realistically do
nothing
so it's an outrageous bar to set to even
compare to
but the real dishonesty is that in the
last 48 hours trump has increased his
expected death toll
by fifty percent from sixty thousand to
ninety thousand
and the way things are going it could
easily be a hundred thousand before we
know it
but trump is immune from criticism
because again without him it would have
been two million
he's now for the first time floated 2.5
million if he did nothing
that's a higher number than he's ever
mentioned before this
is mere politics for donald trump it's
not lives
and one just strange moment during
yesterday's town hall
was again it was a very hopped up trump
who seemed to be
clunching and sweating and visibly on
some on
he was upper trump i don't want to say
what he was on if anything but he was
upper trump
he said that he was asked for schwab's
schwabs
by a governor this is just too funny we
had one governor inslee
who's always wanting something and
frankly
he didn't do a very good job on nursing
homes as far as i'm concerned state of
washington
and he said we need schwabs i said why
don't you get them yourself
but if you can't we'll get them so okay
schwabs a totally lie riddled propaganda
event
a few other notes donald trump said joe
biden wrote him a letter of apology
that's just not true trump once again
started talking about hydroxychloroquine
and told multiple lies about its
efficacy
and trump continues to say that china is
paying for tariffs
i want to take a moment just to explain
that i need everybody in my audience to
understand this and i think most of you
do
trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work trump continues to insist
we're punishing china by putting tariffs
on them
which they are paying us and sometimes
he says it's like a tax on china
please understand that american
companies play the terror pay the
tariffs i know i've said this before
i have to keep repeating it because
trump seems to still not understand
if china sells steel for a thousand
bucks a rod
okay it doesn't matter whatever amount a
thousand bucks a ton
uh and we put a tariff on china china
still
sells that steel for a thousand bucks a
ton
but if there's a 15 tariff on it when an
american company buys it the american
company pays china their thousand bucks
and they pay the government 150 more
dollars american companies
pay the tariffs now if you believe that
this trade war would work china could be
forced to
lower their price and accept the lower
price because of the tariff that
american companies are paying
it's not happening it's not happening
trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work
we are seeing the active and willful
dissemination of weaponized
propaganda but the saddest thing is that
his
followers love it and they see this as a
strong performance
we have one option and it's to remove
trump in november i hope you'll help me
do that
all right let's do a deep dive into
correcting lies this is difficult in our
current political climate donald trump
yesterday
absolutely collapsed like a house of
cards under basic questioning by abc's
david muir yesterday
trump was in arizona went to a mask
factory didn't wear a mask
total propaganda visit but in the middle
of it trump was interviewed by david
muir of abc
uh he didn't really do anything special
other than be a basic journalist asking
trump specific questions
and waiting for an answer and trump's
disintegration
trump became aerosolized let me put it
that way that was the degree of
disintegration it is really something to
behold
uh i'm gonna do something that's a real
pain to do which is i'm going to fact
check three minutes of a trump interview
and it's so lie riddled
that you will notice it takes a lot
longer than three minutes to do the fact
checking and as usual
more people hear the lie very few hear
the correction the correction is
more work this is what we're up against
but let's do it let's do it together
okay
so let's start with david muir presents
trump with a quote
the quote is one you've probably heard
before trump said 15 cases are soon
going to go to zero
let's dig in i'm going to try to fact
check set you
so that you can understand how these
lies are spread and perpetuated
and they become actually like an
alternative truth to trumpists that they
repeat
let's get into the first question here
there was one thing you said that
perhaps you could clarify you said this
this was at the end of february
uh a full month had gone by you'd stop
travel from china
and you said of the cases here in the us
when you have 15 people
and when the 15 within a couple of days
is going to go down to zero
that's a pretty good job we've done help
me understand that moment did you really
think we were going to have 15 cases in
the u.s
let me let me i said even i you would
say worse than that i said one person
one time
and it's true there was a time when we
had one person
in this country we knew about it we
worked on it but we had one person
it mushroomed the 15 people mushroom
other people were coming in also from
europe so already
we have to think this through the
question was when you said we have 15
and they're going to go to zero
how did you come up with that walk us
through how you decided
15 cases were going to go to zero and
trump says
well it was true you know at one point
we did have only 15 cases
at one point we did have only one case
that wasn't the question and one tool
that's really important to have when
you're trying to parse lies from from
government officials or anybody
is are they answering the question
that was asked have they given an answer
and trump has not
the question was not did we really only
have 15 cases at one point of course
right i mean we now have 1.2 million
official cases
at some point we had zero you have to go
through the number 15 to get there
there's no question about that
that wasn't the question the question
was why did you think
15 would go to zero trump doesn't answer
it
let's continue now trump pulls out this
sad
piece of paper he'd been carrying around
all day and it gets very very
uh uh gaslit at this point take a look
don't forget but we're at more than a
million but don't forget in january
okay let's talk about cases you know why
you're in a million cases because we
have more testing than anybody else
if we test it as much as these countries
down here
okay who don't do very much testing at
all look at japan very little testing
there at the bottom of the rung
uh look at south korea get so much
publicity the president of south korea
is a friend of mine
president moon he called up he said what
you're doing with testing is amazing
if i tested this number of people
instead of this number of people i'd
have far fewer
if i see this line goes all the way up
over seven million tests
okay so the graph that trump pulls out
is a linear graph of the total number of
tests that were done and this is really
important to understand because
it's one of the key disinformation
sources right now trump brags
we've tested more than 7 million people
now that's true
but this is a country of 331 million
people
i'm going to sound like a broken record
here but what matters is
per capita per capita testing the u.s
testing 7 million
is different than france testing 7
million because france has a much
smaller population as an example
so when you look at a sampling of
testing per capita
you would see that for example iceland a
small country for sure
iceland is second in the world in
testing per capita they've tested about
150 000 people for every million of
population now they don't even have a
million people
israel is 13th in the world they've
tested
49 000 people per million
portugal is 15th spain is 20th
norway is 26th the united states is
41st in testing per capita we've tested
about 23 000 people for every million
people we have
we are ahead of the uk for example the
uk is 45th
so this is a lie trump won't stop
telling we are
41st in testing per capita
let's keep going with the interview if i
tested
down here at 1 million tests
i would have a lot fewer cases too i
understand the argument you're making
look at your question no but you
understand there's a huge disparity
between 15 and more than a million cases
what was it an intelligence failure
where was the breakdown that we didn't
know the scope of this
look let me let me tell you this um
i closed the border if you want to use
that term
i banned people from coming into china
there were approximately 40 000
americans if you were in my position you
would
let them come in you could ask ron
desantis great governor of florida
those people went through quarantine
they went through tests they went
through everything
but they were american citizens i had to
let them come back in
but i came in and what i did
is i said against many people including
anthony fauci who i like very much
including deborah who i like very much
the doctors and many other people again
trump says he closed the border to china
now
it's true that went into effect on
february 2nd
but understand by that point
45 countries had already closed
travel to china okay it's also not an
answer to the question
an absolute collapse of a performance by
donald trump
here's another portion trump has
repeatedly used this phrase
the cupboards were bare when i came in
and what that means is barack obama
left me under supplied and trump has
used the term to talk about the military
we've already debunked that that's not
true and trump has also applied this to
ppe
for a pandemic here david muir asks him
okay you know you've used this phrase
the cupboards were bare
what did you do to restock the cupboards
and trump essentially says
well you know i was actually busy with
impeachment take a look you know you're
three years into your first term
you're now applying for the job again
what did you do when you became
president
to restock those coverage that you say
were bare well i'll be honest
uh i have a lot of things going on we
had a lot of
people that refused to allow the country
to be successful
they wasted a lot of time on russia
russia russia that turned out to be a
total hoax
then they did ukraine ukraine and that
was a total hoax
then they impeached the president of the
united states for absolutely no reason
and
we even had 197 to nothing vote by the
republicans
understand my friends that one of donald
trump's main defenses of how he handled
coronavirus
is i was given a bad situation by barack
obama
and i fixed it i filled the cupboards
here he's given an
opportunity to say exactly what he did
he could tell us how he filled the
cupboards and he says
well you know i was pretty busy with
impeachment i was pretty busy with the
russia probe and all of that stuff
david muir gives him the opportunity to
silence his critics and say
exactly what he did to fill the
cupboards and he can't do it now let me
tell you the truth and this
this is sort of a bigger picture story
the truth is that barack obama handed
trump
a pandemic response team and trump
disbanded it and bragged about
disbanding it in 2018.
the truth is barack obama handed trump a
pandemic response playbook
69 pages and color coded we've looked at
the document
very good document all trump had to do
was follow it and trump didn't follow it
that's the truth and donald trump unable
to withstand
just basic questioning by abc's david
muir
so trump had to stop press briefings
because they were doing more harm than
good especially after that bleach
injection fiasco
now trump is doing an actual sit-down
interview with someone other than fox
news
and it goes horribly wrong trump has no
choice
seemingly but to just do propaganda
round tables with ceos
because everything else is going
horribly wrong press
uh secretary kelly mcinanny held her
second press briefing yesterday you
might remember that donald
trump's previous secretary uh press
secretary stephanie grisham
held 0.0 press conferences press
briefings during her entire time as
press secretary
kaylee mcinanny did one i believe it was
friday and she did one
yesterday now in her first one she
famously
pledged not to lie to the press then she
told four major lies two related to the
russia investigation
one related to ventilators and one
related to michael flynn so in about
three minutes she uh broke her pledge
not to lie yesterday 12 seconds into the
press briefing she lied
by claiming that the u.s is doing the
most testing merely by saying we've done
seven million tests of course as you all
know
what matters is per capita in a country
of 331 million people
now the last time that we covered her
press briefings
i pointed out the press corps needs to
ask her
about that time she went on fox news in
february
and said trump will never allow
coronavirus to come to the united states
here's what she said back in february
absolutely this president will always
put america first he will always protect
american citizens we will not see
diseases like the coronavirus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing
when contrasting it with the awful
presidency of president obama
kaylee macanally thank you so much good
to see you thank you now
to his credit jeff mason from reuters
yesterday
asked her about exactly those comments
here is how she handled it she turned to
a particular page in her notebook
she knew the question might show up she
was prepared
here's how she addressed it he worked
for the campaign and he made a comment i
believe on fox
in which he said president trump will
not allow the coronavirus to come to
this country
given what has happened since then
obviously
would you like to take that back well
first let me note i was asked a question
on fox business about president's travel
restrictions i noted
what was the intent behind those travel
restrictions which is we will not see
the coronavirus come here
we will not see terrorism come here
referring to an earlier set of travel
restrictions
i guess i would turn the question back
on the media and ask similar questions
does vox want to take back that they
proclaim that the coronavirus would not
be a deadly pandemic
does the washington post want to take
back that they told americans to get a
grip the flu is bigger than the
coronavirus
does the washington post likewise want
to take back that our brains are causing
us to exaggerate
the threat of the coronavirus does the
new york times want to take back
that fear of the virus may be spreading
faster than the virus itself
does npr want to take back that the flu
was a much bigger threat than the
coronavirus
and finally once again the washington
post would they like to take back that
the government should not respond
aggressively
to the coronavirus i'll leave you with
those questions and maybe you'll have
some answers
in a few days
what's so funny about this is that she
clearly feels like that was a huge mic
drop moment
where she walks off after turning it
back around on the press
it's actually cringe-worthy and the
entire thing was cringe-worthy uh
she may not last long because it's it's
getting more and more embarrassing
now the trumpets seem to be liking it
that's what might keep her in the job
she starts the briefing 35 minutes late
it lasts
only 25 minutes total after taking only
a few questions
she abruptly walks off after being asked
about a completely laughable
ridiculous thing that she said but the
trumpets love it donald trump
don jr tweeted yesterday saying her
answer was
fire and a whole bunch of trumpists are
just
thrilled with kaylee mcinanni so let's
analyze her argument
she said trump won't let coronavirus
come to the united states
and she responds by saying listen a lot
of media outlets said
uh this is not going to be a big deal in
the united states that's a terrible
argument
number one it's not really an argument
it's actually the two quote
fallacy uh which is the appeal to
hypocrisy is another way to say it
which is when you try to discredit your
opponent's
argument about something you did by
pointing out that someone else
did the same thing and that it's it's
fallacious strictly speaking
how can the media criticize her when
they said similar things supposedly is
the way the argument goes
now first of all when the media was
saying
this may not be a big deal in the united
states the media
was reporting what different medical
experts were saying
many of whom were people that were
involved with the trump administration
and
so so one thing to understand is a lot
of the articles she's quoting
are articles that are essentially citing
the medical experts
that the trump administration picked to
say things about coronavirus that's
number one
it's not like the media reports uh when
you look at
independent and foreign experts we're
not saying this would be a big deal in
fact
you can look at january and february and
find a whole bunch of media reports
that are not based on what
trump-affiliated medical experts were
saying if you look at foreign countries
if you look at independent agencies in
the u.s
they were saying we could take actions
that would prevent this
but if we don't it's going to be a
disaster so she's she's actually wrong
about that
and a lot of the reports that she cites
were simply saying
here's what someone associated with the
administration says is going to happen
she didn't say here's what an expert
says she simply said trump won't allow
the virus to come here
so she made a very different type of
claim when she went on fox news and said
obama's presidency was awful trump's not
going to allow it to come here that was
not
these are the medical experts alleging
that now secondly
none of those media people who were
simply reporting what was being said
were hired to be trump's press secretary
right
the question about her competence is a
very valid and good question because
she was hired to be trump's press
secretary some vox writer
who quoted a health expert who may have
been wrong or may have been taken out
or whatever they are not now speaking
for the president but
clearly what she has done is show her
hand she is very much willing to attack
the media
she is prepared to attack the media
whenever she gets a question she doesn't
like
very much like donald trump does that's
what we've learned
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram
at david pakman show we'll be back very
soon
hey this is really interesting there's a
few republican governors
who have been ignoring if not completely
abandoning donald trump when it comes to
dealing with the virus in their states
and their popularity has absolutely
exploded i'm talking
mostly about ohio republican governor
mike dewine
he's done a pretty good job of handling
coronavirus from day one although
more recently there are some concerns
about the policies he's rolling out but
he's mostly been following health
experts and not donald trump
and his popularity has soared we also
have been looking at how maryland
republican governor larry hogan
has been dealing with the virus and then
our own governor here in massachusetts
charlie baker
a republican as well has been doing a
pretty good job
and the reason that we care about this
is that the november of 2020 elections
are in many ways referendums
that's the it's not referenda i looked
it up referendums
on donald trump when we look at the
senate race in north carolina with
republican tom tillis
or we look at uh martha mcsally in
arizona
or you look at susan collins in maine
these are in large part
adjudications of the trump regime and so
far it's not going particularly well for
those republicans
many republicans have been afraid of
contradicting or crossing donald trump
because they're afraid it might be bad
for their local and state races
trump might target me it could be really
really bad but what we're seeing is that
ohio republican governor mike dewine
has absolutely split from trump and he
is hugely benefiting from it in terms of
approval in terms of popularity
and this may be a signal for 2020 six
months away we can't say for sure but it
may be a signal
what did mike dewine do mike dewine
locked down ohio early
before other republicans took it
seriously before donald trump was even
taking it
seriously he's been doing regular
briefings that are actually
fact-based and they attract democrats
and republicans in ohio and even
nationally people are watching these
much like andrew cuomo's briefings
conservative activists and business
leaders have been pressuring dewine to
do what trump wants start reopening do
all this stuff
and dewine just hasn't done it and he's
been listening
to the health experts he also came out
in favor of a mail-in primary
late last month trump has been viciously
opposed to mail-in voting
and then more recently this week dewine
has started to loosen up some of the
guidelines as businesses can start
opening
masks are recommended six feet
separation is recommended for workers
and customers
and for a while before this 30 or more
republicans in the state legislature
were demanding that dewine open
everything right away
and he didn't do it splitting with trump
and his approval on coronavirus
is 85 his trustworthiness rating
is 89 on coronavirus
you don't get those numbers with just
republicans
he's taking testing seriously he says
they're going to roughly
triple testing by the end of the month
in ohio from seven
thousand a day to twenty thousand a day
and what's interesting is that when we
look at maryland and
massachusetts republican governors in
blue states
you kind of have to as a republican
governor
follow what your liberal state
legislatures want you to do
massachusetts has a republican governor
and charlie baker but a very left
legislature and a
relatively left voting public so it's
not surprising that charlie baker is
doing more
what our state wants rather than what
trump wants but ohio
it's certainly a battleground state but
it's not a left-wing stronghold of any
kind so you might imagine that what mike
dewine has done in abandoning trump
would be far more risky but it has
worked here in massachusetts charlie
baker former ceo of a big health
insurance company
i didn't vote for him i'm not looking to
have more and more governors
be former ceos of health insurance
companies but
charlie baker knows how to delegate he
knows how to trust experts and he knows
how to look at data
remember that dr burks laughably claimed
that trump
looks at data and makes decisions by
assimilating the information we all knew
it was bs
what we want to see is governors
actually do
what dewine has been doing to some
degree what charlie baker and hogan have
been doing
i'm hopeful that as a result on may 18th
here in massachusetts charlie baker will
be able to announce
some loosening of certain guidelines if
the numbers keep improving
yesterday here in massachusetts we had
only 1.4 percent case growth
that's really low we had a week of about
3 percent daily case growth that's
really not bad so competence is
important
ideology is less important here armed
protesters aside
for the most part we've seen people
across the country
approve of competence even across party
lines
massachusetts voters overwhelmingly
pleased with republican charlie baker
despite being a blue state
ohio voters democrats and republicans
nearly 90 percent approval
on coronavirus trustworthiness for the
republican governor
who has abandoned the doctrine of donald
trump
again this may be a big signal for how
november of 2020 may go
hopefully we don't know we've got to
count every single vote
we have to cast every ballot but that is
the upside to what we are seeing
we'll have continued coverage of this on
the david pakman show
instagram page at davidpakmanshow
follow me while you're there at
david.pakman2
we are in a 100-year global pandemic and
our president
is dramatically mishandling it so i do
want to keep you apprised as to
what he's been up to for the last 72 or
so hours
uh donald trump spent the weekend at
camp david did a fox news
virtual town hall on sunday night and
then he basically took yesterday off if
you look at donald trump's schedule for
monday
you find nothing on it and yet yesterday
was a really big day
in a sense we are fighting coronavirus
we learned
of documents from the cdc and fema told
you about the documents earlier they
predict that we will
spike to 3 000 american deaths a day by
june 1st
hopefully not true but certainly
something to be taken very seriously
we found out states are rapidly running
out of unemployment money
we found out that states without enough
social distancing are starting to see
large spikes in cases
on a percentage basis the numbers may
still be relatively small
but percentage-wise you are seeing
sometimes the case growth
double from one day to the next so we
learned
last week that even when trump does do
work he often is showing up at noon
after watching tv for five to seven
hours
a day and sending out outrageous tweets
yesterday was a clear schedule
except for nearly 24 hours of
rage tweeting 6am to 1am
okay i mean we're talking about 19 hours
of tweeting here
all day and night spent tweeting
outrageous attacks
and untruths starting with attacks on
the press bright and early
saying quote concast as he calls comcast
should open up a long overdue florida
cold case against
psycho joe scarborough i know him and
crazy mika well
used them beautifully in the last
election dumped them nicely
and will state on the record that he is
nuts
besides bad ratings so attack on
msnbc attack on two specific journalists
media people
joe scarborough and mika brzezinski
three attacks it's uh like 6 30 in the
morning
then trump goes directly into talking
about his coronavirus ratings another
obsession
saying quote getting great reviews
finally
for how well we are handling the
pandemic especially our strong
production of desperately needed
ventilators the building of field
hospitals and beds and soon the great
things we are doing on testing
people are really working well together
understand
that 1200 people died on sunday another
bunch died yesterday
and trump is tweeting about reviews
ratings and getting credit this is a
very sick person this is an acutely
unwell individual trump bragging then
about something which actually has been
a huge accomplishment for him
which is one of the main reasons that
it's an emergency to remove
him in november which is judges donald
trump tweeted yesterday
republicans love the biggest tax cuts
rebuilt military choice for vets which
was an obama program by the way saving
second amendment and many other things
my administration
has done but what they love beyond all
else
is 252 so far
federal judges not including two great
supreme court justices
a big record trump is right trump
in in collusion with mitch mcconnell
have put in place
judges hundreds of judges who will
decide
law and cases for your children
and grandchildren in some cases that is
how long they are going to be in power
he is right about this one and he must
be stopped
then trump attacking california saying
mexico is sadly experiencing very big
virus problems and now california get
this
doesn't want people coming over the
southern border a classic
they are so lucky that i am their
president
border is very tight and the wall is
rapidly being built
so to date to this point of the day he's
attacked msnbc joe scarborough mika
brzezinski and california
as well as bragging about ratings then
trump
again bragging about testing a favorite
topic and if trump is talking about
testing
you know he's lying he said quote by
congress not wanting
the special five-minute testing
apparatus they are saying that they are
not essential
in any event we have great testing
capacity and have performed
6.5 million tests which is more than
every country in the world combined
remember we have the receipts the united
states is currently 41st
in testing per capita globally we're
behind canada
but we're ahead of belarus we have 331
million people
testing six million means that after two
months of this
we've only tested two percent of the
population what matters is our testing
rate not the number of tests we are 41st
in the world our death rate on the other
hand is the 14th
highest death rate in the world don't
take my word for it go look up the
numbers
then later last night trump attacking
msnbc
again but also uh cnn tweeting
msdnc and fake news cnn are going
wild trying to protect china and then
this was
really late last night it was like 1am
but
it's so insane i'm going to count it
trump very triggered
by a new political ad against him with a
multi-tweet rant
get a load of this trump saying this is
this is rage from a president in the
middle of the night
it is very acutely unwell
uh it's a sign of trump being ill saying
quote a group of rhino republicans who
failed badly 12 years ago then again
eight years ago
and then got badly beaten by me a
political first timer four years ago
have copied no imagination the concept
of an ad from ronald reagan
mourning in america doing everything
possible to get even
for all of their many failures you see
these loser types don't care about 252
new federal judges
two great supreme court justices a
rebuilt military a protected second
amendment
biggest ever tax and regulation cuts and
much more
i didn't use any of them because they
don't know how to win
and their so-called lincoln project is a
disgrace to honest abe
i don't know what kellyanne did to her
deranged
loser of a husband moonface but it must
have been really bad
john weaver lost big for kasich to me
crazed rick wilson who's been on this
show
lost for evan mcmuffin mcmullen to me
steve schmidt and reed galvin lost for
john mccain
romney's campaign manager lost to big o
and jennifer horn got thrown out of the
new hampshire republican party
they're all losers but abe lincoln
republican
is all smiles the unintellig
unintelligible
rantings of a lunatic a triggered
lunatic
so it's a day with nothing scheduled for
donald trump after his weekend at camp
david
riddled with nonsense on twitter during
which he attacked
msnbc cnn joe scarborough mikko
brzezinski california
some republicans kellyanne conway's
husband george conway
republican strategists rick wilson uh
steve schmidt
evan mcmullen mitt romney's campaign
manager whose name he doesn't know
and jennifer horn while bragging about
his coronavirus ratings
and lying about coronavirus testing this
was just monday
this was just monday he also spent the
weekend rage tweeting
with all sorts of different claims
including that journalist nicole wallace
was
thrown off of the view quote like a dog
like a dog that is the president of the
united states
thanks to 60 something million americans
we must act
in november so we're starting to see
sort of a new divide in the fight
against coronavirus earlier you had
these metro areas with larger population
densities
more flights directly to china you
started seeing those areas have more
cases pretty early so new york city
certainly at the top of that list
boston would be another example as well
and you've got places that are less
connected to the global economy having
fewer cases early on we are now starting
to see
a divergence where the numbers are
starting to improve pretty dramatically
in some of these early hot spots in
terms of a reduction in cases
and a reduction in deaths and a
reduction in serious cases and people in
icus
but we have a new wave of cases in
places that have been insisting all
along hey i don't know that we need to
close we don't have any cases
and very quickly they are getting many
many more cases
and they still seem to not understand
how viral growth
works now let's look at one example and
that's mississippi
republican governor tate reeves was
insisting for weeks
mississippi can open we can open
mississippi everything's great here
and indeed he decided to go ahead and
open businesses the cases
spiked and he is canceling that plan
he's calling it a pause but okay i mean
eventually businesses will open
the plan to open now has been cancelled
friday mississippi
had about 400 new cases and 20 new
deaths and they have changed
their plans governor tate reeves should
actually be applauded for doing this we
shouldn't make fun of the fact that his
initial plan was wrong
he should be praised because he's
actually looking at the data and
changing the plan
because when you look at other places
that have started to open
uh and it's still in some cases we don't
even see the full effect yet places like
florida
are quickly finding more and more new
cases despite
still having pretty low levels of
testing virginia
is now finding close to a thousand new
cases a day
texas is finding close to a thousand new
cases a day and they're only testing
a third or a quarter of what places like
massachusetts and rhode island and new
york are testing
if you're only testing 14 000 people a
day
and you're finding a thousand new cases
a day those numbers are going to go up
even faster as you start to test more
indiana is another place that supposedly
had no problem they were all set to go
one of the top growth rates by
percentage now
over the weekend ohio becoming a hot
spot
georgia may be the hot spot by the end
of the week as governor kemp there
has just blown the doors wide open
georgia has nearly
30 000 cases now i believe that if we
had stayed
as close to fully shut down as possible
just two more weeks everywhere we would
have been
in a good position to have more testing
by then
and to be able to start easing
restrictions and guidelines
but now a lot of these states are going
to fall very very far back here in
massachusetts republican governor
charlie baker extended the stay-at-home
order it was supposed to end today may
4.
charlie baker has extended it by two
weeks to may 18th
and we've seen cases level off we've got
about a three percent
new case rate per day and it hasn't been
climbing
we've seen a net decrease in
hospitalizations
over the last week deaths have dropped
from
close to 200 a day to about 100 a day
still a lot still tragic but that's the
direction you want to see things going
my instinct is that in another 14 days
if massachusetts keeps doing this the
numbers are going to look dramatically
better
the opposite seems to be happening in
many southern states
now i want to praise mississippi they
had a plan
we thought it was the wrong plan many of
us did they looked at the data
and they changed the plan we can focus
on it was a bad plan to start with and
it was a bad plan to start with
but lots of states have bad plans and
many of them aren't changing the plans
as the data changes georgia texas and
florida are examples
at least governor tate reeves realized
the plan
doesn't match the data and we have to
change our plan
mississippi is a place with the worst
health care in the country
according to u.s news 50th out of 50.
they can't risk having their system
overwhelmed
which would lead to a very high death
rate he changed his mind and that's
great
let's see what happens in these other
places as cases spike texas and georgia
we will be following closely all week
many states
now also have armed protesters demanding
that they be reopened
protesters showing up yelling at cops
typically not wearing
face masks very very ugly stuff